who did you grow up wanting to play for
believing I wanted to play for the
Toronto Raptors why I was a big Vince
Carter fan I dug through anger power and
I would live for that you want to see a
show this is what I have to offer I got
to experience the ultimate high and the
vaults below all in one day the low of
missing the game-winning shot game seven
to go on to the Conference Finals
regardless of if you hate me you think I
can't play I can play but I'm not belong
here with the fifth pick in the 1998 NBA
Draft the Golden State Warriors select
Vince Carter from the University of
North
I'd like to announce a trade
[Music]
Toronto has traded the rights to Antwon
Jameson to Golden State for the rights
to Vince Carter Vince tell me how
excited you are about playing in Toronto
I'm excited I had a great workout out
there and I'm really looking forward to
it daddy's guys the big bus up north no
doubt about it
thank you the informer at UNC Tar Heel
basketball has begun to mean something
in Canada harder of course a big reason
why they wrapped his baby headed to the
playoffs Carter won the award at the NBA
Rookie of the Month in March to Vince
Carter may not be bigger than the CN
Tower
but the rookie phenom is pretty darn
close
[Applause]
the hardest first season was one long
as he earned the [ __ ] riki of you
my favorite is
just smashed it down
[Music]
[Music]
against cars doing dunks that dr. J used
to do but you know making it look even
better dunk contest is something that
I've always wanted to do I took the dunk
contest serious like I felt like it was
a playoff approach as far as I'm coming
here focused on trying the week
I said I want to be the dunk contest
because I watched it I study disrespect
ultimate goal dream
Dantas was like it's old forever
I'm in my zone
I am in dunk artists the biggest night
of my life
I wasn't afraid to fail
two seconds one second beats of
[Applause]
I felt like I want to show the world
what I can do
[Applause]
with the greatest of ease I ask you one
question to fill in the blank when it's
all said and done at the end of my
career I want people to say that he made
a difference on the court and off the
court
mentally
that is physical
I don't want you just to label me as
Vince Carter the dunker but he can do a
lot of things and that's kind of where
my focus was
talk about you going to Canada what was
your first thoughts to my surprise is
one of the best-kept secrets for me is
one of the best places ever I mean they
were learning with me
[Applause]
it turns out it's that left Achilles
again he said he felt at poverty just
aggravated it when he was jumping was
just frustrated in the game I come home
and still felt like he got blown out the
rumblings of Vince Carter wants out the
Raptors won a trade Vince called
it was rather frustrating for me to hear
that and to really understand and grasp
it so it was like all Vince didn't work
won't want to be here and so on and so
forth just the hatred I just couldn't
understand him you could tell advance
that if it's gonna be like this you know
I don't want to be here I don't want to
go for anymore
why not for what so the main source of
sports entertainment in Canada these
days is generally Raptors basketball and
all-star Vince Carter in particular but
not anymore
Friday trade sent to Air Canada to the
Nets for Alonzo Mourning two other
players I'm just gonna step in and knock
down open shots and get a couple of
dunks here then and we'll see what
happens from there I just wanted to
prove to to everyone like I still got it
I'm still capable I'm still able to play
this game I don't think any player has
ever been booed like that night
[Music]
[Applause]
well it's been a remarkable turnaround
for Vince Carter especially when you
consider his last few years in Toronto
but he left it all behind when he was
traded New Jersey
what he's done over the past few months
may just top them all leading the Nets
on a dramatic run to a playoff berth and
I've never ever not played 100% for the
people that know me they know I will
never ever disrespect the game like that
Vince Carter Michael Jordan and yourself
in the prime who wins a dunk contest
Vince of the game but talk about large
this is a special dog and you know the
way Vince dunks the ball was
unbelievable it's awesome it's know if
there was we would've did okay I like
down
how do you explain your tremendous
increase in production all of a sudden
you never a little point he makes my job
easier
you got Jason Kidd who makes everybody
better he makes Vince Carter a lot
better
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm still here I still love the game you
know the numbers speak for itself
history speaks for itself so I leave
that to other and I never say oh look at
the numbers one of the great games ever
turned in by a New Jersey net and one of
the great opponent Knights against Miami
and they gotta tip your hat and respect
the 51 point performance by Vince Carter
but I don't feel uncomfortable coming in
here and play and I feel at home the top
train on draft date
Vince Carter moving on again I think
he's gonna have a great year with
Orlando I think he's going to with Vince
Carter the Phoenix Suns were their
leading scorer Jason Richardson and Hedo
Turkoglu whoever you had to say I'm
gonna show you [ __ ] sugar a veteran
making his way to Dallas and Vince
Carter still chasing the elusive
championship
[Applause]
be smarter no we're trying to get the 20
right I play the game of basketball
because I just love being able to
persevere the tough time
they just showed a video tribute and
harder has received a standing ovation
Vince Carter heads out to Sacramento and
he is doing this one more time
why is this car still planned because I
love play men well this is good signing
for the latter
[Applause]
I'll tell you what it's a huge weight
lifted off my shoulder but man this is
awesome
he changed the culture dare Toronto you
know I bought Toronto from being up
learning new things in the lead is
almost going to the final I want to be
like this
[Applause]
not only am i doing it for the love and
what I know I love doing I do it for the
game and respect to the game and the
players that played when I don't want to
put the work in anymore
I'm settling away I just can't imagine
it right now because I still feel like I
can compete